hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast and
[Music]
just checking in on you i'm just just
checking in on you seeing how you doing
seeing all your weeks going
huh you're back to work you're not
wearing a mask or a condom
ain't got no coverage on either red man
[ __ ] it
um yeah do you think whatever the [ __ ]
you gives a [ __ ] nobody cares
it's over um these [ __ ] ants god damn
it how many [ __ ] ants do you have to
kill before the other ants know not to
come in here
that's what i want to know i hate
putting the raid on them you know
such a [ __ ] way to kill [ __ ] ants
you know and then somebody else gets it
on their feet and then a bird eats it
and then the bird dies
and then that chick writes that that
that book silence spring that i was
meaning to read but i just knew it was
gonna be too much of a [ __ ] bummer
um i wonder why hollywood hasn't made a
movie about her
this woman she was just like you know
these pesticides are great but if you
start you know you send them all
willy-nilly out there uh you know you
could really be [ __ ] up the uh
wildlife
they were like shut up [ __ ] you got a
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's 1959 go [ __ ] yourself
i got
big hairy balls here and a [ __ ] lab
coat
and you just never heard from her again
and usually hollywood tries to give
these people voices
um oh god i am [ __ ] burned out but i
gotta knock this out cause i got a bunch
of [ __ ]
to do tomorrow a bunch of zoom calls
come on and zoom zoom zuma zoom remember
that kid show
we're gonna zoom
give it a try we're going to show you
just why
we're going to teach you to fly hi check
it out it's a thing
it was a boston show right zoom z double
o m box three
five o boston mass o two one
three four send it to zoom [ __ ] you
there was no cable back then what do you
want from me all right
you give me a bunch of long-haired kids
with striped shirts i'm gonna [ __ ]
watch them
that's what happened that's what i did
zoom had no [ __ ] idea what it what
what it was or what it was about but i
can tell you this it's thursday
everybody if you're listening to this
it's thursday september 10th
2020 and what papa
nfl football starts up tonight with your
defending super bowl champions the
kansas city chiefs
they ended a i don't know how many
[ __ ] year drought
40-year drought 40 seasons anyway
they won it 1970 now they won in 2019
patrick now
was trying to put his name in the
[ __ ] the all-time record he got one
now he's got to try to get another one
right but who's gonna try to stalk oh
it's the texans with [ __ ] jj watt
oh [ __ ] super-sized dudley do-right
and he's like just a second damn mr
mahomes
um i don't know how to hype these
[ __ ] games i'll tell you my
knowledge of sports already sucked and
now i got two kids that i don't even
know what's going on i know my [ __ ]
new england patriots with cat
on the center are playing the [ __ ]
miami dolphins the dolphins always
playing stuff they always somehow figure
out a way to split
uh the two games you know the the the
season series these divisional rivals
they really know each other well
um six and a half points is the point
spread
is the point spread um and tampa bay has
the saints
all right so i don't know what the
[ __ ] gonna happen all i know is we
lost like five guys on defense
i know our only viable option
at the wide receiver position like last
year was edelman
and they double covered him so we need
somebody else to step up there
okay where have we improved we have a
quarterback for the first time
in 30 years whose legs work
okay we went from drew bledsoe to tom
brady
all right a patriot they had that dude
bishop for a minute
in the late 90s that dude could [ __ ]
move
um but other than that yeah it's been a
long time since we had a mobile
quarterback
so i'm hoping
as you hope with any quarterback that he
does not have to run because when
quarterbacks run
quarterbacks get hurt uh so we shall see
what happens we got all kinds of new
people on defense
uh my corner seemed to be pretty good
but the heart of the defense
dante hightower's not there that other
[ __ ] guy
left a couple more people i don't know
the [ __ ] names
and uh our offensive line we still have
shaq mason
with the other dude to the right of him
whatever his [ __ ] name is i just
looked it up i can't remember already
uh i recognized his name and then we got
it just seems like all new people
the other way so hopefully seems like we
have a decent running game i have no
[ __ ] idea what the patriots gonna be
like but i'm really looking as a
football fan
to watch bill belichick design
a game plan i mean if he can around the
skills
of cam newton if he can do it for matt
castle he can do it for [ __ ] cap
newton you know we can't
um and then i'm also excited to watch
tom brady
go into one of the great [ __ ]
stadiums
it was already a great stadium it was
already iconic
the new orleans superdome and then ever
since they redid it
and somehow kept the integrity of the
[ __ ]
original structure but made it even just
way better
um the mercedes-benz superdome whatever
they call it uh
we shall see we shall see what happens
both those teams i guess notoriously get
off the slow starts i have no idea what
else is going on around the league you
know i can tell you
if i didn't have [ __ ] internet that
takes nine years ah look at that blue
look at the blue it starts it always
gives me a nice [ __ ] third
of of the juice and then it just stops i
don't know what to tell you
do you guys have any suggestions on how
i can get my [ __ ] internet to work
better out here over my garage
i am all [ __ ] is
um anyway i got to tell you what i the
[ __ ] i've been doing oh by the way by
the way
the [ __ ] celtics lost a brutal one
tonight double overtime incredible
[ __ ] game from what i heard
i watched the first half of the game and
then uh life took over
okay cooking dinner baths and all of
that [ __ ] and um
lost it double overtime once again how
big was that [ __ ] shot that kid on
toronto hit
they were looking at going down 0-3
okay oh [ __ ] three and he hits that
with like
point [ __ ] four seconds left a three
pointer to
to steal the [ __ ] game how big is
that is the celtics are now facing a
game
seven against the uh toronto raptors i
still feel good like we're gonna win it
because i kind of they've been kind of
been going back and forth since that
three-pointer
um well actually no we lost two games in
a row
i must oh [ __ ] we've lost three of the
last four well god damn it we gotta do
something
um i got confidence i got confidence
and um but jesus christ who's waiting
for us after that is the [ __ ] miami
heat
who beat the [ __ ] out of the milwaukee
bucks
speaking of that the clippers are
beating the [ __ ] out of the [ __ ]
pacers
lakers are up 2-1 over houston
[ __ ] unbelievable that western
conference finals clippers and lakers
you know some i know i [ __ ] all over the
nba hoop with the super teams and all
that i'm done being this [ __ ] old man
i really figured out why i don't like
basketball
i'm just not emotionally built to sit
there and go through
the levels of ups and downs in a
basketball game
the fact that your [ __ ] team can be
up 17 points
and then [ __ ] some eight foot dude
comes off the bench and hits three three
pointers in a row
cuts the lead in half and next thing you
know you're going in half time you only
have a two-point lead
i i just i can't handle that i can't
have it's like you got it's like
it's like you're [ __ ] bipolar we're
up 25
yeah we got this [ __ ] game and i was
like 27
two run uh who saw that call of the
gates i'll tie it up 106 right out six
it's just like i can't [ __ ] do this
and then and then the final [ __ ]
three minutes takes like [ __ ] half an
hour i can't [ __ ] do it
i can't do it i walk in and out of the
room i can't that's why i like i like
fast sports get it over with rip the
[ __ ] band-aid off
this [ __ ] goddamn hoop i just i can't
handle it
i can't handle it speaking of hockey
tampa bay
wins the first two games against the
islanders
great [ __ ] hockey name sorry guys i'm
[ __ ]
exhausted here scored the next one two
to one
so it's looking like tampa bay but
dallas won so who knows who knows who's
gonna be in the west but it's
tampa bay's i don't know they just look
like the best team and they're showing
that they are in the east so we shall
see
what happens tampa bay lightning looking
to win
their second stanley cup
since they've been a franchise since
what like 1997
i want to say i don't know 95 93 when
the [ __ ] did they come in i have no idea
they won in 2004. just the thing about a
[ __ ]
florida expansion team those
win quick all right the dolphins came in
in like what
66 by 72 they had a perfect season one
back to back they never won again but
whatever they still did it right
the [ __ ] miami heat came in in 88
well that took a minute
22 years but still there's 30 teams
they still got in there quicker right
those guys all got on a boat say hey man
what if we all got on the same team man
oh that would be great man
and then they [ __ ] won a couple two
three down there right oh wait a second
what am i talking about shaq one
with uh with the the guy there
one of the great players dating uh you
know married to the the the [ __ ]
actress there
the [ __ ] his name dwyane wade
what the [ __ ] got a [ __ ] hand on my
goddamn screen
um
did they win two dwayne wade won two
with him
with shaq one he won one that's right
and then
then shaq did the rap that's right i
remember that [ __ ] um
then who else florida panthers never won
[ __ ] [ __ ]
uh the florida marlins i don't know when
the [ __ ] they came out sometime in the
90s
big bang boom they won [ __ ] two world
series before the celtics even
the red sox broke the curse
all right let's go north orlando they
should have won one but [ __ ] had
uh not [ __ ] had shaq left and then
[ __ ]
um then they got another big center and
he left dwight
dwight howard they both leave like
that's what i don't like about you
what do you do as an orlando fan uh for
the
sixth selection the orlando magic select
future laker center and champion in los
angeles
that's what they do although uh dwight
howard never uh
won a championship out there or i don't
think he's won a championship period
um i don't think he has i don't [ __ ]
know
all right the lightning won a cup
tampa bay buccaneers they won a super
bowl i mean they're [ __ ] successful
down there jacksonville yeah
you know what are you gonna do but i
mean they got like nine teams down there
ten [ __ ] teams
and they all seem to be doing it um but
then you got other [ __ ] cities you
get expansion teams and it's just like
why did you do this to us
we weren't even paying to the attention
to this sport and then you [ __ ]
[ __ ] come along
you get into my heart and now i give a
[ __ ] and you can't hold on to anybody
that's what i'm worried about with the
new orleans pelicans
they already lost new orleans already
lost the [ __ ] jazz
and those [ __ ] nerds out there in
utah never changed the goddamn name
well we're kind of jazzy out here i have
jazzy's
pants on let's keep the name um
this is my thing i actually don't think
that the utah jazz
are gonna [ __ ] win until they change
the name of their team
that's what i think all right
it's the new orleans jazz that made
sense
utah jazz makes no sense what they
should do
is call them the utah um
i have 13 wives mind your own business
whatever the [ __ ]
whatever those people do out there i
don't know what it is
um the new orleans blue eyes uh the [ __ ]
heads no i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm
talking about anyways
oh jesus christ you can you believe i'm
not i'm not drinking
that's what i want to talk about okay i
have fallen in love with this [ __ ]
show are you guys watching cobra kai
please tell me you're watching it um
it's the reboot of
the original karate kid which came out
when i was like i don't know 15 16 years
old
i loved that [ __ ] movie and i got to
tell you something i cannot
say enough about how great this [ __ ]
show is it is so goddamn entertaining
it's just everything it's dramatic it
makes fun
of itself it's hilarious it's sad
it makes you think i'm just i just i
[ __ ]
love it um
cannot say enough about it and i got to
tell you something
uh william zabka
absolutely is destroying
on this thing ralph macchio destroying
on it just
watching the two of them back on screen
again
and they didn't screw it up whoever
wrote this thing however
it's just they're killing it they're
killing so many times they go to the
well
they go back to something that worked
and then they [ __ ] it all
up this is the exact opposite of it it
might be the great i mean i don't know
how many
shows they've done or reboot or or
brought something back to life whatever
that is
this has to be at the top of the list um
it's such a good show me and my wife
made a rule that we can only
watch two episodes a night so we don't
burn through it we've gotten through the
whole first season
um if you're a fan of it
if you just like a great show i just
cannot say enough of it
dude william zadka is [ __ ] hilarious
his character is [ __ ] hilarious and
sad and you root for the guy
i mean just the job that he's doing um
is insane and it's just why i've always
said that acting is one of the hardest
[ __ ] jobs out there
because this guy has been this good for
this [ __ ] long and when i was growing
up they always had him play the same guy
he was the good-looking guy
who you know who was just sort of the
foil for the person that you're supposed
to be rooting for
and i don't know i always found myself
rooting for him
in the movies you know not in cobra kai
when he [ __ ] elbowed the dude's knee
i mean i wasn't rooting for that part
but i like i always like he had that he
had that leading man charisma so
now see him finally getting this is is
is just a really great thing it's such
such a crazy [ __ ] business who would
ever think 30 years later
um you'd get to see something like this
jesus christ
more than that at this point because it
was a youtube
series i guess and i remember hearing
about it brett ertz is in it
and he was saying goes dude you should
watch it man it's [ __ ] good and i was
being a snob oh
show on youtube i'm not gonna watch that
you know i go online
i might go on youtube i i watch uh you
know i watch [ __ ]
afl championship games from [ __ ]
50 years ago i don't know what the
[ __ ] wrong with me
um anyway you gotta [ __ ] see it you
have to see it i am
uh hats off to everybody involved in
that thing
everybody dude ralph macchio is
hilarious in it his characters
where the where they both ended up is so
interesting
i mean it's just one of those all the
great shows i've ever watched
within three minutes i was like i'm just
like
i'm in i'm watching every [ __ ] second
of this this is
this is great it's one of those shows um
and i got to tell you it's been a minute
it's been a minute since i i've i've
seen a show like this that got me this
excited so congratulations
to everybody in it i wish i knew more of
the actors names but whatever it's
[ __ ] late night i just got my kids to
bed so
cobra kai on netflix thank god
for netflix bringing it that's the
number one show i guess in the united
states
um such a great story so check it out if
you get a chance
ringing endorsement if you didn't know
what the [ __ ] that was that was a
ringing
endorsement um all right i guess now i
would be the time when i would take a
break
to do a little bit of ad reads you know
what i mean
hang on a second let me [ __ ] see here
let me see if i can text andrew
the malay littles um
there we go this is how much i've gotten
into that [ __ ]
cobra kai and then seeing you know doing
flashbacks to like
the karate kid and [ __ ] i'm like
downloading music from the 80s
than i never even bought the first time
um you know what i mean like there's
just this
there's that weird [ __ ] thing you'll
see it if you're young when you get
older
there'll be bands that you're like that
[ __ ] bad sucks
yeah i ain't [ __ ] they're [ __ ]
[ __ ] you're not gonna listen and then
all of a sudden
years like go by and you finally you're
older or whatever and you listen to it
again and it just takes you back to that
decade
like and i'm gonna [ __ ] listen to
this [ __ ] there was so much [ __ ] in the
80s that i just
refused to listen to unless there were
two guitar players a bass player
uh a [ __ ] drummer with double bass
just i was just in the metal that's all
i [ __ ] listened to
and and i just missed out on all of that
all that other [ __ ] i don't know what
well i just missed out on all of it
so um actually even though they haven't
played in this music in cobra kai it
made me go back to sort of that
time and uh i was listening some 80s
music
and my daughter was enjoying uh this
song by the cars called you might think
and i was just like you know all these
years i've been a fan of that band
i just never downloaded any of their
stuff they're just one of those bands
where
it's like tom petty it's like i don't
need to down
or buy this guy's music his entire
catalog is on the radio
like when you get people just know how
to write a [ __ ] song
that everybody's gonna like like it just
becomes pointless to even buy their
music because
the second you shut it off you're gonna
turn on the radio and it's gonna be on i
just always felt like tom
petty and the heartbreakers were like
that and the cars were like that
these are like bands that had like i
feel like they had 80 hits
um so i actually went i downloaded some
uh
some music by the greatest hits of the
cars
and um it's really like interesting
music because it's pop music
it it it's weird it's like really pop
but it also
it was considered like it had balls
it's such a such a weird time in music
too with all that new wave [ __ ] i don't
know i don't know if i'm using the right
terms
but like there was this weird thing in
the 80s where if
like there was this hard line with
keyboards
where there was no room for keyboards in
hard rock music there was this whole
[ __ ] thing with that
but then like the cars would come out
and they had their great sound and
keyboards were all up in the whole
[ __ ] thing
but the whole thing worked and like they
they would somehow
get a pass and i remember
like like bon jovi was one of those
groups that separated people like
how metal you were you know secretly we
all like their music but like you know
i know there's been sketches done on
this but it's just so hard to stand up
and play a keyboard
and [ __ ] look cool i i don't know
what it i don't know why
when like [ __ ] those early rock and
rollers would play a piano and they're
standing up and playing it with their
foot and everything like that was
that was still cool you know and if you
look like a lot of the lead guitar
players they were still in a lot of
chuck berry stage moves and that was
still [ __ ] working
but keyboard players trying to [ __ ]
rock out
like little richard and jerry lee lewis
and all them when they would do it it
just
i don't know it just [ __ ] it just
didn't work
and that was like a big [ __ ] thing
with like
van halen i mean i think keyboards broke
the [ __ ] band up
the first time at least that's what i'm
sure was a bunch of other [ __ ] but like
when uh 1984 came out and it opened with
like a keyboard
instrumental um
there was all like these uh you know van
halen purists
going like uh you know there should be
no keyboard i listened to van halen to
listen to eddie play guitar right
um and then of course you listen to the
alvin's [ __ ] killer album
but that was like such a huge [ __ ]
divide in the music that i was listening
to like the keyboard the keyboard was
the beginning of the end
and then so many bands too listened to
their their hardcore fan base
and your hardcore fan base you know
wants the band to live the same life
that they're living which is
they don't want change they want to go
to the same [ __ ] burger place they
still want to wear their football jacket
they still want to stay in their [ __ ]
hometown
and they want their [ __ ] band to keep
writing the same [ __ ]
types of songs in the same key with the
same [ __ ] instruments
and that's why i find bands like uh
say like you too that really sort of at
one point just made a decision that okay
we have if we're gonna
stick around for the long haul we have
to change
and know that we are based it's like a
rocket going up in space you know when
the sections burn off like you're taking
your original fan base
and a section of them is going to burn
because to this day like you know these
[ __ ] guys my age
you know they don't even like the
unforgettable fire they're like i think
the best album was boy
i don't know [ __ ] about youtube by the
way i don't know anything about that to
me that they
they were punk rock that's how far away
from that kind of music i was i know
that they're not but
when i was a kid like i thought that
that's what they were
you know he sort of had a mohawk you
know he sort of was wearing those
same type of army boots um
and the guitar didn't seem to have like
that growl like the [ __ ] that i was
listening to so i was just like well
this isn't like lame i kind of like this
but
i don't know what this is so i'll just
say this is punk rock
you know what it was was the kids up the
street were into punk rock and they
loved you too
so i just assumed that this was just
part of
that [ __ ] i don't [ __ ] know i don't
know a lot of things people
but i do know this i am [ __ ] uh
i'm exhausted i got so much [ __ ] [ __ ]
to do tomorrow and once i knock it out
once i knock once i get i just gotta get
past monday once i get past monday [ __ ]
gets normal again although i think this
weekend
i'm gonna be having a good time you know
stretch it out wait am i it's [ __ ]
nfl football what the [ __ ] i have to do
when i screw this up
every year is i forget to make sure i
have the nfl package
you know and then i'm gonna be like
every other [ __ ] guy that doesn't
understand computers and i'm going to be
sitting on the phone tomorrow
trying to call them up or what i could
do is go to nfl.com and just order it
there
right and then doesn't like somehow like
my
laptop interact with my tv can i do that
and then i can just project it
onto the thing do you know one year
somebody got me for christmas they got
me one of these i need help guys
this this [ __ ] got me this projection
tv right and not a project tv get me
a projector is what they were called
when i was a kid
and somehow the tv goes through this
thing and then this thing just projects
tv
onto a [ __ ] flat surface surface
right
so what i want to do
is i have you know this the side of my
house
where there's no windows there's a place
where i can sit down i mean if i could
somehow
get the tv to be talking to the
projector to
shoot it onto the side of my house and i
could sit there in a chair
you know underneath the [ __ ] spf 900
[ __ ] umbrella
and smoke a cigar and watch a baseball
game or a football game
um and neglect my family i think i could
really have a good time so
um does anybody know how to do that
you know i've actually been getting
better at this [ __ ] i just sit down and
i just keep [ __ ]
looking and i try and figure it out i
just figure
come on man give me the sunday ticket
where is it
new scores schedule videos teams players
stats standings kickoff
nfl network fantasy tickets
shop signing
ah you know i can't do it on this
[ __ ] internet you know what i'm gonna
i'll figure this [ __ ] out
i will figure this [ __ ] out um
yeah cause i'm gonna be traveling when
it comes to uh
the next couple weeks i'm gonna be out
in connecticut
standing out in a [ __ ] pasture
telling my jokes
and then i'll be down in new jersey i'll
be traveling a lot and i want to be
watching
the uh all the games the
nhl and nba how crazy is this nhl
playoffs nba playoffs
baseball and [ __ ]
football all going on at the same time
beginning of september
this usually happens briefly right
with the world's serious there in
october
i don't know i love when they all
overlap um so we shall see anyways
that is the podcast my prediction what
is your prediction celtic swing game
seven
against toronto i'm not saying that
because i'm celtics fan i just really
think that we're going to beat them
i don't know why and i'm going to age a
thousand years watching that
i think the patriots
oh that's a tough one this is a tough
one i'm going to say that they
they get an ugly win because i think
it's going to take some time
it all depends on what the whoever the
number two receiver is if that guy can
just be a [ __ ] problem
and get some catches and be somebody
that they have to pay attention to
then we got him and edelman right
i don't know we shall see that's my
prediction and i think tom brady comes
out with the win
two-minute offense i think it's gonna be
an epic battle him and drew brees
the two elder statesmen in the league
and uh you realize tom brady is like
the rolling stones right and [ __ ]
drew brees is like aerosmith like no one
really talks about how old drew brees
is the way they do about tom because tom
brady still play
right and for the longest time nobody
said that aerosmith was old because the
rolling stones were still playing you
know what i mean
because no matter how old aerosmith was
[ __ ] the rolling stones were still
[ __ ]
you know 10 years older than him it kind
of worked out and i feel like that's
that's what drew brees is doing
like no matter how old he is like tom
brady's like four or five years older
than him
right does that make sense i don't
[ __ ] know all right listen that's the
podcast
uh thank you to everybody by the way who
uh bought up the tickets
um when i go back east i really
appreciate that i had no idea what was
gonna go on i know a lot of you guys
everybody's [ __ ] struggling and it
means the world to me that you guys
still want to come out and see me um i'm
going to do some parking lot
shows out here i plan to
[ __ ] go off on these shows
um i i cannot i cannot wait
to be doing this and it's going to be
football season and i'll be past
this little bit of work here that i got
to get past here so i'll be in a great
great great mood i'm going to see a
bunch of people that i haven't seen
in a long time coming out to the shows
and um you know family and friends
because we can't you know travel during
this [ __ ] time at least we can't you
know what i mean well when maybe you
[ __ ]
you know grew a dick took off your
[ __ ] master's old goddamn host
um i can't believe people are still
doing that it's just like this is not a
political issue
please listen to scientists or don't i
don't
and then help tank the [ __ ] economy
and then uh
you know when the whole thing goes to
[ __ ] just blame the political party you
don't like okay that that
i think that's what adults oh look who
it is
me undies no more [ __ ] keyboards do
do
do do be undies be undies the crowd is
[ __ ]
bored you're rocking out but
nobody cares they're all hoping that
you fall down the stairs that you walked
up to that [ __ ] [ __ ] keyboard
there's the room for that instrument and
rock
take out your axe um hey
pick up your axe um the undies everybody
you know we saw one leaf fall on the
ground yesterday that so that can only
mean one thing
fall is finally coming it's time to book
your booties
ties bow ties booties
ready for the spookiest time of year
with the softest undies to grace your
bottom oh it is booties
me undies knows exactly how to celebrate
a season with the coolest prince and
colors
and the softest undies known to man they
want you to be comfortable to express
yourself
every day and in every way how ready are
you for the fall
and halloween huh you got your printed
undies
their undies grow on trees no seriously
they're made of irresistibly soft
natural fiber source from beechwood
trees and you know
what natural fibers mean that means
micro modal
is not only super soft but breathable
light and impossible cozy wait once you
get to the whole [ __ ] how you
build the underwear no one gives a [ __ ]
is it soft against your balls
you made your point get to the website
never run out of undies with the
undies membership a subscription that
sends new pairs right to your door plus
get site-wide savings and exclusive
sales
keep your eyes peeled for their spooky
cool halloween prints meundies has a
great offer for my listeners
for any first time purchaser get 15 off
your and free shipping
this is a no-brainer especially because
they have a 100 satisfaction guarantee
get your 15
off your first order free shipping and
100 satisfaction guarantee go to
meundies.com
that's meundies.com
okay policy genius is up next
september is national life insurance
awareness month
month month month month uh but with
everything going on right now a lot of
people aren't even aware
it's possible to buy life insurance at
all the good news
is that it's all easy to shop for life
insurance right now all you
all and if you have loved ones sorry
depending on your income you probably
should right now
you could save 1500 bucks or more a year
by using policy genius to compare life
insurance policies
when you're shopping for a policy that
could last decades or more
those savings really start to add up
well [ __ ] that's 15 grand in 10 years
what is policy genius it's an insurance
marketplace built in backed by a team of
industry experts here's how it works
step one head to policygenius.com
in minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need and compare quotes
from top insurers to find your best
price step two
two apply for your lowest price step
three
the policy genius team will handle all
the paperwork and red tape policy genius
works for you
not the insurance company so if you hit
any speed bumps during the application
process process they'll take care of
everything
they even have policies which allow
eligible customers to skip the in-person
medical exam
and do it over the phone how do you feel
i feel great
you're insured uh that part that kind of
service
has earned policy genius a five-star
rating across
over 1600 reviews on trustpilot and
google so
if you need life insurance head over to
policygenius.com right now
to get started you could save fifteen
hundred dollars of moa
a year by comparing quotes on their
marketplace policy genius
for all you smarties out there geniuses
g-e-n-i-u-s
when it comes to insurance it's nice to
get it right
all right all right this has been old
billy dum dum
talking for another half hour of his
life
uh duh i'll tell you about all the work
i got next
next monday i'll tell you about some
well yeah next monday yeah next monday
i'll talk to you about that [ __ ] all the
[ __ ] i got [ __ ]
coming up here and hopefully i can
promote some stuff and hopefully you'll
check it out all right that's it
uh enjoy the music and we have a bonus
episode of the thursday
uh monday morning thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast
um a bonus episode from a couple years
ago or whatever however we pick it up
all right that's it
have a great weekend you [ __ ] go pats
go celtics
go red sox go [ __ ] yourself please enjoy
my segment on the sports gambling
podcast with sean greene
and ryan kramer bill burr on the sports
gaming podcast is brought to you by
mybookie.edu
head over to mybookie.ed to get in on
all the nfl action and use the promo
code bur
for a 100 deposit bonus that's my
bookie.ag promo code burr
joining us on the line actor and
comedian bill burr
bill it's great to have you back on the
show but it's also great to be talking
nfl week one how excited are you that
football's back
i was just telling you guys i was so
excited i thought it was today
because i got to do a podcast with
somebody i'm like why did he reschedule
for five o'clock
west coast time and my buddy had to talk
me down like dude it's tomorrow i can't
wait i'm so psyched that the nfl is
playing
some college football too sec yeah sec
red state they wearing no
leather helmets they don't give a [ __ ]
no it is funny how the
the college conferences just broke down
on party lines like
hey if you have a red state governor
you're definitely playing college
football
blue state oh you can't even mention the
word football
yeah joe bartnick from the puck off
podcast was the one who
turned me on to that whole idea i was
like oh my god he's right
yeah joe's great hilarious comic great
nhl podcast
well of course the patriots the big
story obviously
tom brady out cam newton in now
and for me right now i'm seeing the
chatter
it's a love fest right now cam newton oh
my god i love the organization bill
belichick
hyping up a player in the media i never
thought i'd see that
the fans seem to be buying in but i i
don't know man how long do you think the
leash is
for cam newton i can just imagine a
three interception game he comes out to
the press conference wearing one of
those hats and a scarf and
just the city turns on him how long do
you think the honeymoon lasts
listen the problem out here is nobody
can see this thing clearly because
they've hated the patriots for so long
and they've done everything
saying oh they they took the moisture
out of our sharpies in our locker room
that's why we lost by 35.
people hate us so much and they so want
us to have a losing season
that rather than getting into
how much fun if you're truly a football
fan this is going to be to see tom and
bill belichick
separated and then to see what belichick
does with cam newton and you know our
receiving core is you know i don't know
where that's at we lost five guys on
defense
there's a lot of stuff going on where
i'm anticipating we start
slow and everybody in the sports talk
media was like sure they have given tom
the money
and i think tampa bay starts slow i
think there's so many new moving parts
people have to get familiar i think
you're going to see a lot of tom and cam
newton doing this stuff being like i
thought you were going to the inside you
broke outside
and i bet early on that they're gonna be
saying stuff like uh was this a bad move
for both people they're gonna be doing
all of that
they should never have broken up they
were perfect for each other what's gonna
happen
i think this is just you know comedian
here well organized football class
pre-season and third grade my dad saw
cte come and he pulled me out of it
he was he was ahead of the the curve
there with the cctv
knocking your brains out out there bill
well that is that
that seinfeld bit where he said you know
he's breaking down football and it's
like instead of avoiding the head
cracking activities
we just developed a helmet so that we
could still do the head cracking
activities
yes exactly um so i would say that
what i feel like this i think they're
both going to start off not saying
they're going to lose but i just think
it's going to it's going to be clunky
you're going to try to get on the same
page
and the disease of of the internet and
24 hour sports news network
to keep the plate spinning negative
has more inertia yeah easier to keep it
going then if you go like well you know
just give them a couple of weeks
um so well and i'm looking forward to
all of it and
one of my favorite seasons real quickly
of watching bill belichick coach
was when tom brady unfortunately got
hurt and you got to see matt castle come
in and you watched him design
an offense around a guy's skill set
which is like i mean there's coaches as
great as they are they do what they
do and if they plug you in you can't do
what they do then you're out
belichick can like like adapt um
so i think in the long run
it's gonna be a great thing i mean cam
newton's an unbelievable player um
and and i i also like that we're going
to see
who is right yes no it's difficult
or is the panthers maybe not the
greatest organization
and i'm leaning towards uh i don't want
to trash the panthers but i just
feel like i just feel like you know
you know this there's a lot of uh
there's a lot of i mean we got camden
if you're going to lose tom brady to get
news
and you know it worked out well for the
patriots because it pissed everyone off
i mean
cam noon penny's on the dollar and i
think we already kind of know there were
some issues with the carolina franchise
before that so yeah no obviously bill
belichick does not praise players and
that's the thing that you notice he's
praising cam newton's work ethic
so i think there's gonna be so excited
he finally has a mobile quarterback
he went from drew bledsoe to tom brady i
mean they're
two statues you're about as slow as i am
but i i think um
it's exciting to see tom in uh
tampa where i i heard they have a decent
offensive line great offensive weapons
and everything
but going up against the saints i mean i
mean that's their division i feel like
and uh you got drew brees in like like
i just really feel this week you know
tampa bay going up against the saints
the saints is a solidified unit
where i feel like tampa like the
patriots is is gonna it's gonna
gel as the season goes so i think
there's gonna be a lot of overreactions
one way or the other yeah like is it
gonna be cam and tom in the super bowl
or is it or it's gonna be like
this was a big mistake for both people
well
and the patriots they've normally
treated september in the past years as
the preseason
and then especially with no preseason
them starting slow
is not out of the realm of possibility
and to specifically get to that game
opening day week one they're at home
against the dolphins who always kind of
give them trouble the dolphins coming
into town they always split against
us and uh you would have thought that
we'd get them but the thing was is they
used to kick our ass all the time
because they went from bob greasy to dan
marino
so that was like almost a 30-year beat
down between the two of them
and then we started you know splitting
with bledsoe and then we won a lot with
brady but even with brady and some of
our best teams
there's just something about your
division rivals they they know you
they're not afraid of you
it's just um it's and it's also the
greatest thing
that the nfl has is parody so that you
know
every game counts as um that's why i
fell out of love with the nba i just
can't get into the pylon teams i can't
yeah
82 games and then just stars becoming
friends and like
forming these super groups it's just
great to have we all get on a yacht and
just decide where we're all going to
play next year it's just what if we all
just got on the same bus
i mean the
with the bubble i mean the bubble could
have been out on a giant yacht
or like an aircraft carrier it's just a
bunch of guys hanging out having a great
life which is fun
and god bless them but uh it's not
you're missing the intensity
that you get with the nfl if you stop
the description before you explain that
there's basketball going on in the
bubble it is the
it's the bachelorette so it's it's a new
world
no although there's a lot of good stuff
i like what milwaukee was doing and i
think uh
uh jerry ferrara called the heat before
the uh the playoffs so
he's looking like he's it's looking
pretty good well yeah and jimmy butler
is one of those old school guys who just
doesn't give a [ __ ] and seems like he
actually hates guys out there and
i'm so pissed the sixers let him go like
we need an intense guy like that
on our team all right back to the
dolphins patriots
no no no this is i i mean uh how dare
you interrupt football talk with
basketball talk
the dolphins are getting six and a half
in new england to me
that line feels way too high especially
i mean the last game the dolphins played
they went in
and knocked the patriots out of the well
not out of the playoffs but out of the
out of uh having to buy for the playoffs
i don't think they're scared to go in
there and compete and again
to your point i think cam is gonna have
just struggle with the flow with the
continuity and miami's coming in
i think brian flores is a great coach
i'm on the dolphins catching six and a
half bill
it sounds like you think it'll probably
end up being a close game where are you
at with that one
yeah i mean i don't think you can really
compete last year i mean we have a
completely different team but the
dolphins i think
but they picked up some guys i got that
kid from buffalo
and i heard they got a decent running
game um
i i like the dolphins and the points i
hate
i mean i obviously i think the patriots
are gonna win i'm rooting for my team
but you know i got two kids so if i'm
trying to make some money here
i like you know ryan fitzpatrick said
like they're just solid
um i'm still i don't know what the
patriots have
last year our biggest problem at wide
receiver was it was edelman
it was the edelman show so they would
just double him
and we just lost too many nobody else
was a problem so they they could kind of
shut him down but the only way to shut
down
edelman is the double the guy and that's
what they did so that became a problem
so i know running games are right but i
just think it's going to
um a close game however
however the mobility of cam newton
yeah to pick up those first downs when
people are covered
might cause them to cheat in they say oh
this is why gambling
i always pick the perfect number but no
it's it's it's right there where
great number uh but i i would take i
i would take dolphins uh and i would
take the points
kramer you're uh you're also team
dolphins i mean what are they doing when
they're laying six and a half
they're begging you to take the patriots
they're saying hey look it's not seven
and while i think cam i do think cam
could be successful because he has
athleticism because i'm sure that
they've designed a
offense that will work from the get-go
probably a lot of designed runs
a lot of read option but yeah i'm taking
the points because i have no clue i mean
cam newton hasn't looked good in a long
time
i i i i love that that's why we got him
for nothing dude let me tell you
something if anybody's helping
bilo sell him he's open that guy can
stand in the pocket too i'm already
defending him i'm on yeah no wait let's
go
drinking the cam cool as you take the
dog with the points as will i
sean or is it is it a trifecta yeah well
i don't know i was just saying
i don't i don't look at kim like he's an
athletic no you're right
he can play the position and he can run
like a wide receiver
well and go into the other uh the other
game where brady's making his debut
in a bucks jersey in new orleans and
again they kind of
have the perfect line here where you
could make a case for both sides
the bucks are getting three and a half
points in new orleans
i'm gonna take the bucks here i'm i have
a lot of questions of them for the
entire season i do think they end up
winning the nfc south and if you look at
new orleans
has had a history also kind of like the
patriots great team
you know win a ton of regular season
games but they start slow like if you
look at the last six years
in the first two games they're combined
two and ten with the two-point win
against the texans
how much did that how many players are
gone from them i love when they go over
the last 30 years when it's outside and
they're reigning
after guys in the stat are like dead
what does that mean i don't know what
that means this is my favorite tradition
of every year
well i built shits on sean's trends from
three years ago it's great i just don't
understand
i don't get it i dust off the trends i
throw them out there
i'm being a great point guard setting a
bill for the
six when they played on this surface
against a team named after a bird
it's just like i don't know what that is
i will say
are they who's going to be checking the
saints to keep that decibel level
to 70. yeah because it's no fans and
they have a history
of rigging crowd noise but i mean that's
a tough spot i i hear you sean but a
tough spot to go in in new orleans no
matter fans or not
has a history of that the indianapolis
cult oh well
yeah the cult's probably a little bit
let's throw some crap their way those
pieces
never never trust a team that plays in a
dome never trust a team that plays in a
dome
yeah they're like they got caught too
yeah they all get caught they're right
it's about seattle seattle stadium
sounds like a dome i went to a game
there
talking as loud as there like the way
they designed that thing man it's i mean
good on them they got away with it
yeah no you feel like you're in like an
echo chamber literally
and anything you say yeah you know
whatever
yeah i mean seattle is like the formula
one teams just trying to find loopholes
in the rules they they found a way to
make that stadium loud without a roof so
so bill what are you doing in this game
tampa bay getting three and a half
points in new orleans feels like it
should be a close game
i got it this is crazy this is crazy
game because i'm
my whole my gut is just telling me drew
brees
the saints at home but it's tom brady
you can't quit him tom brady i'm telling
you right now he's doing what joe
montana did
late in his career he goes to a new team
uh joe montana
made kansas city a playoff team did not
win a ring if you think that's not
motivating this guy
he's not gonna come out there button
heads going let's go
i gotta go i gotta go with tom brady and
he's
he's got his buddy gronk there i i think
and bruce arians you know he's just been
sitting there
the entire offseason just salivating at
this game
it means this game opening night means
way more i think to the
bucks uh than to the saints just because
it's not it's not a must win for the
saints but
in a weird way i do feel like it's a
must win almost for
tom brady at least he's going to be
feeling that pressure yeah and he's
certainly a guy who's
stepped up to the plate no he doesn't
unless it's coming from his backside
and then he slides gets the ball
downfield
well bill uh you mentioned you uh oh
jesus was
you just giving him [ __ ] he's got six
rings no no no i was saying he feels
pressure meaning
he has great pocket awareness it was it
was a compliment i wasn't
if i was if i was going to bust these
chops i'd start talking about super bowl
but i don't need to go there dude you
know what i love about you eagle fans
you went
one in one and you're acting like you
were undefeated
hey i just want to applaud your
quarterback for not puking in the huddle
hey mcnabb he had a little uh stomach
virus there flyers do
oh god that's right
of all those the uh the celtics sweeping
fixers
60 philadelphia eagles and let's not
forget the 48 and 49.
nfl title two yes exactly and chuck bed
and eric who is
jersey is framed hanging in my living
room and i can't find the clip
but my favorite one of my favorite nfl
film clips ever
is a bet i say his name baton eric
bednarik yeah he's from my hometown
they asked him what do you think about
today's game and he just goes i
wouldn't watch today's football game and
you paid me
you got all you got all like his neck he
made dick butkus and like
mike ditka looked chill he was a guy
with his fingers
like this oh yes he was uh he's from my
hometown bethlehem pennsylvania and we
had a
football awards banquet and he came
there that was like the big thing chuck
bed and eric's gonna give you the trophy
and uh he hands it and you're right like
he had that mangled
hand where his like finger is like 90
degrees the other way
his pinky was literally like 90 degrees
here's the thing about
philly is i love all your teams it's
your fans
yeah that make me root against them i
was happy for you guys
you know i mean i would like that the
patriots won but i was happy that you
guys won it but then you guys
i don't know you got you know what you
guys are like philly fans you like a
comic that's just
dirty for for dirty sink shotgun
they've rubbed your balls all these yeah
they do batteries it's santa claus
which is really just a misdirection
because they're stabbing people to death
out on the west coast
did you throw snowballs at somebody now
you guys gotta top each other so you
gotta like puke on
on a little girl i just feel like at
this point it's just like uh
it's like fast and the furious part
seven i mean it's it's
it's run its course well for i i was
against puking on the uh little girl
i was as an eagles fan i'm against that
but you're right it is funny how eagles
and like patriots fans i'll lump you
guys in there get a ton of crap
but then dodgers fans are putting guys
in comas and like crazy things
go out in the west coast but they always
shot during a pre-season 49ers
eagles game i mean a raiders game yeah
who cares that much about pre-season i
mean sean we almost watched someone get
stabbed at a 49ers
and the guy goes you want to talk about
the ravens
breaks it and then it's just like going
around the parking lot
it's not a joke out here like it's it's
not the east coast is with fists only
you know it's like
it's like the producers you know behind
home plate
those guys aren't intense fans but don't
kid yourself there are intense crazy
fans yeah
roaming the lots and and and getting
into it
bill i appreciate you calling in before
we let you go the 83
sixers are my favorite team of all time
and i would put them up against the 96
bulls
moses malone against luke longley i'll
take that all day
yeah i mean it was so fun watching that
that jordan dock and and getting to
relive some of those bulls teams but
yeah i mean there were plenty of good
teams in the 80s especially that could
probably hang with those uh
those mid-air balls dr jay i think is
gonna do enough to help out
moses is going to dominate luke longley
you got
uh the boston strangler andrew tony mo
cheeks come on yeah they could never use
a nickname like that now boston
strangler oh that's too problematic
we're not going to use that you could
not that's
one of the greatest names ever that guy
was
unconscious when he went into the boston
garden it's a different sport because
what's his face to this day i heard
danny ain't still tells horror stories
about him
trying to guard him because it wasn't
like playing jordan he goes [ __ ] jordan
andrew tony yeah that guy was like
hitting him from like the hot dog stand
well those are the guys you got to worry
about the guys with nothing to lose the
guys that are out there just
to make a name for yeah he themselves
and player dude that guy was a player
what happened to him was he had
uh foot problems it cut his career short
but anybody who played with him there
was you know when that guy was on there
was nobody like him
you know i i put it to he wore the
low-cut dr jace
he didn't wear the high-tops but he
didn't have ankle problems
you know i don't know [ __ ] whatever i
said bet against it
that's that is that is that going to be
your lock for week one
take uh bill's picks and go against what
i heard was
been against the patriots bet on tom
brady so there you go
that's uh that's how you heard it no i
said the patriots are still going to win
they're not going to cover
okay so imagine you're about that and do
you have do you have tampa bay covering
the three and a half winning outright
where are you at with that one
um i had them oh are they gonna kick a
field goal to win it in the end and not
cover
oh no tampa tampa tampa tampa is gonna
win tampa is gonna come in
win the game outright uh and that's
probably because i i love tom brady
all right that's your love of tom brady
talking tb bill baby
appreciate you calling in the podcast
and uh yeah make sure you follow
bill on on twitter check out f is for
family
and uh king of staten island as well
thanks bill appreciate the time man go
pax i'll see you thanks for checking out
the sports gaming podcast make sure you
subscribe to our podcast to hear us pick
every nfl game against the spread and
give us a follow on twitter at
gamblingpodcast
and of course if you want to play win
and get paid go to mybookie.ag
promo code burr
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill byrne it's
the monday morning podcast for monday
september 10th
2012. um i'm doing this [ __ ] late at
night
uh i just got done after a whirlwind
weekend here at the improv in orlando
florida i would like to thank everyone
who came out to my shows
[ __ ] hardcore man place was packed on
a sunday night
when there was sunday night football you
know
when frankenstein was coming back for
the broncos
with his fused goddamn neck and
everybody's
wants to [ __ ] tune in and be like
what's he gonna be like
is he gonna be like the old peyton
manning who [ __ ] killed everybody and
then
lost in the first round of the playoffs
and blamed everyone else
or is he going to be the new peyton
manning you know
doing a face plant like a [ __ ] lawn
dart and then going i don't like
colorado
you know turning his whole body to see
you i gotta tell you something man that
[ __ ]
looked he looked great
he looked fine and fine for peyton
manning he's great i know he [ __ ] all
over the guy but i obviously totally
respect the guy
that guy looked [ __ ] great he didn't
look like did he look like he was
towards
even towards the end of his career he
looked like he was in the middle of his
career
okay and as much as i shat all over that
guy
when he played for the [ __ ] colts i
don't want to see him go out like that
i don't see him go out like [ __ ]
brett favre
you know what i mean where he looked
like he got rescued by jesus you know
that when they just find your clothes on
the ground
that's what that's what brett favre
looked like when he got stuck
that final time and he was laying it
looked like he
like his body his spirit just left and
they would go over when they went to
turn him over there would just be the
jersey and there'd be no brett favre in
there
where did he go his spirit went back
down new orleans went back down there to
them [ __ ] swamps
um i got to watch a good like maybe like
the third quarter on to the fourth
quarter and uh
it was actually great because it was a
bunch of steelers fans there
and the broncos won so you know it's
just fun
it's fun to watch people get all excited
and then lose i i really enjoyed it
and i'm just also watching like how
[ __ ] nuts sports fans are
this guy he kept slapping the bar three
times and then he would slap
like this [ __ ] beam above him three
times completely out of rhythm
and i was like why is he doing that and
i realized it was like some sort of
[ __ ]
ocd like i gotta hit this three times
then hit that thing three times to even
it out
because if i don't the steelers aren't
going to win so he did that every
[ __ ] time and they still lost
they still [ __ ] lost i want to give a
shout out to that woman who came up with
their [ __ ] back out by the way
that was tremendous the end of the show
everybody's coming by to get
pictures it's a bunch of drunk guys
slapping me on the back this [ __ ]
hardy came up
right i do the usual arm around the back
here we go
nothing but [ __ ] sexy back like that
little kid from the boy band used to
sing about wham
i don't understand justin timberlake
he's like the coolest [ __ ] ever
on stage and then when he's off stage
and starts talking he sounds like a def
jam comic
imitating a white guy you know
or he sounds like tony gwynn one of the
other
tony gwen is the [ __ ] he's the black
guy that breaks the stereotype
of uh it sounded like a black guy
remember that from the oj trial
how do you know it was a black guy it
sounded like a black guy and everybody
what
what does that mean you know what it
means
you know i used to do a bit of buzz one
of the first jokes i did
that is you heard something oh i'm gonna
[ __ ] kill you i was the worst [ __ ]
hacky asian accent ever but whatever you
know what i'm saying
you wouldn't think that it was a [ __ ]
a black dude right
whatever and i stood by that joke until
tony gwynn started commentating
uh baseball and he would be like
yeah i sat down with uh
i sat down with chad williams you know
mr baseball life
i'm not even like he's even [ __ ]
worse than that
even worse than that um
anyways i don't know where the [ __ ] i'm
going with any of this [ __ ] oh i missed
the tennis today did sereno did serena
win
oh here it is all right i'll commentate
right now and the ball is going over and
it just went over to go out
oh and he's like what the [ __ ] oh no it
was in
oh these are guys i thought it was
ladies thought it was the ladies
that's how effeminate tennis is you know
and go ahead and defend tennis how it's
manly because you push through
shin splints nobody gives a [ __ ]
all right andy roddick retired
you always look like ashton kutcher to
me i thought they were like from the
same [ __ ] gene pool
oh so this guy novak de jokovic he
always [ __ ] wins everything
get to the ladies serena williams did
she win
that's a fun sport to go to by the way i
went to the u.s open a couple of times
you know what i mean going there hanging
out with like bankers and then just
regular douche bags like me
and it's just that that whole we're
[ __ ] better than you vibe
maybe with their little white shirts on
what the [ __ ] was i talking about this
this podcast is going to be all over the
place by the way this is why i don't do
them at night okay because i'm all out
of comedy
by this time of night i've already done
a set i'm all out i'm all out of comedy
i'm so lost without you
um why do sports commentators wear suits
why do they wear shirt and [ __ ] ties
with a goddamn suit on like what you're
doing
is any sort of a real [ __ ] what are
you doing
having a [ __ ] baseball hat you got to
wear you got to sit there like a [ __ ]
real estate agent to tell me if
vancouver won or not
huh all right who's happy this week who
isn't
with your football teams do you guys see
troy uh paula malu
do you see him i actually tweeted about
this this mother twittered however the
[ __ ] you say
he he actually after years
of watching defensive backs get
stiff-armed
and thinking that there was nothing you
could [ __ ] do about the stiff arm
somebody please give me a clip because i
want to post it troy palamalu
solved the stiff arm puzzle
this guy went he was known for his stiff
arm he went he went out and gave
troy a stiff arm and troy simply grabbed
the [ __ ] arm which is something
nobody ever thought to do
it was like the big brother holding the
little brother back and you'd still try
to punch him in the ribs and you
couldn't do it nobody ever thought to
attack the arm
it was like some bruce lee [ __ ] the
[ __ ] arm is part of the body
troy just [ __ ] reached up grabbed
this guy's arm
and did like this [ __ ] ufc
mma judo [ __ ] i don't know what
somebody on twitter said he did
basically the the alligator [ __ ]
death roll with this guy's arm and i
literally it looked like the guy's arm
did like a [ __ ] 360 and he flipped
this guy down on the ground
and all the announcers said they just
said something like it was some sort of
arm drag rather than being like did this
guy just [ __ ] do what i've never seen
anybody do before in my life
all right so you saw history you saw a
guy kick a 63-yard field goal
on the san francisco 49ers and you saw
the stiff arm is no longer a viable
weapon
thanks to troy thanks to you it works
for all of us
the united way oh they're showing the
highlights right now just
how [ __ ] up does peyton manning look
and that ugly orange shirt
those are really ugly uniforms why are
they wearing that they should go back
don't they have the blue shirted one
[ __ ] goddamn peyton man did you know
he was gonna come back out and just be
the exact same guy
um what are you guys thinking out there
in uh colt's land
you upset you had to make the move the
guy's neck got fused
look at him he's running down the
[ __ ] field this is ridiculous high
fiving people
ben roethlisberger happy feet oh throws
a [ __ ] pick six dice the goddamn game
it's over
peyton manning does not look right in
that [ __ ] jesus christ i think i
would look better in that jersey and i'm
a redhead
and you know we can't go anywhere near
orange that's our [ __ ] kryptonite
was the last time you saw redhead
wearing an orange shirt
you're [ __ ] lying it's never happened
i just can't get comfortable in these
[ __ ] hotel chairs
um oh you know what happened to me this
weekend
that's me trying to eat up time rather
than just telling you oh you know what
happened to me
like i'm saying oh hey gather round
that's another thing too i have to watch
how loud i [ __ ] talk here
so i don't offend people you know i went
to [ __ ] whole foods
to try to make sure i was gonna eat
healthy this weekend
why are these [ __ ] chairs so goddamn
heavy yet such pieces
of [ __ ] they [ __ ] waterlogged
i just wanted to buy raisin bran and
they have [ __ ] cascadian farm
organic raisin bran and you know what i
got to say after
eating a half a box of that give me the
trans fat one
give me the one that eats away at my
liver because that one's way better that
one that has the [ __ ] angel dust on
it
i enjoy that one immensely so anyways um
you know i'm staying at this hotel it's
[ __ ] nice hotel
haven't you like i said that like you
said it wasn't a [ __ ] nice hotel
um i'm having a good time i'm enjoying
myself
doing what it is that i do right i go
down to the lobby all of a sudden
there's like [ __ ]
20 security guys down there 20 guys
oh [ __ ] what about rg3 look at this
highlight
[ __ ] paul verzi you guys want to
break his balls and it's v-i-r-z-i
not v-e-r do you want to break his balls
on twitter you know what he [ __ ]
texts me
he goes the saints are going to win by
14 today it's a lock
no doubt
that's why i love paul paul is never
unsure of himself or at least never
speaks like he is
he's never it's always like dude it's a
lock paul's never seen something
that wasn't a lock you know that's what
he that's the genius
of what he does he just says it's a lock
there's no [ __ ] doubt about it
you know and then when it finally comes
in you know he tries to act like he's a
genius and that everybody forgets
the other 50 things that he said was a
lock so that's the first thing
that he said that he's been wrong about
he picked somebody else too i can't even
remember who it was i hope he was wrong
about that too and i hope he's listening
um so anyways i go down to the god damn
uh
the lobby and uh
all of a sudden there's like 20 security
people there and a metal detector
right it's it's like what
okay i why did this all of a sudden turn
into the [ __ ] airport what's going on
here
and then just like i was starting to go
outside because i was waiting for my
ride to go over to the club right
and uh what the [ __ ] is with this
goddamn mixer this thing has been so
quiet lately
all of a sudden i'm not getting any
readings hello test
there we go um
it's beyond unprofessional um
so they tell me oh if you go outside if
you come back in you got to go through
the metal detector so now i'm being a
pissy [ __ ]
so the [ __ ] guy from the club calls
me and he goes where are you at i can't
drive in i go i don't know
you can't drive in all of a sudden the
cops have it blocked off some [ __ ]
big shots coming in that's what i said
you know i thought it was like prince
you know not really thinking about the
metal detector i was like who the [ __ ]
is this or whatever it turned out it was
the president of the united states
uh obama you know what's funny
i can't even remember what his first
name is obama
that's his last name what's his first
name thurgood
is he one of those blue blood names what
the [ __ ] is his name barack
when was the last time you heard anybody
call him barack
i wish i saw him i would have said that
if i could remember it i'll call him
thurgood
piss him off even more so yeah the
president was staying at my hotel
so i had to come back in late at night
right i was coming back with some
[ __ ] uh
fast food i was getting a ride from uh
duncan jay who asked me nine times to
give him a shout out on the podcast
you know nobody likes a desperate
comedian duncan
nobody anyways he's [ __ ] give me a
ride back from
sonic burger wherever the [ __ ] we came
from i got a cheeseburger fry i got the
number 13 with the coke
so we [ __ ] go to pull into the hotel
and every you know it's all these
security guys saying sir like 15 times
and then saying i need you to
that's like whenever you go to security
school they always tell you that you say
sir i'm gonna need you to sir i'm gonna
need you to not stand there
is that what you're gonna need your
[ __ ] douchebag
i [ __ ] hate people who tell me what
to do
all right i'm a [ __ ] guest in this
hotel i was here first i've been going
in and out of that [ __ ] door without
shooting anybody [ __ ] off okay
i'm gonna need you to [ __ ] off don't you
wish you had like two like [ __ ] nine
bodies
so you could just sacrifice one just
every once in a while
so i could just say that to a secret
service person
get snapped and [ __ ] half but i would
just still have the satisfaction of just
not [ __ ] holding it in
and then you know once he snaps me in
half i just grab another one out of the
closet
another pasty [ __ ] torso and twist it
onto my milk white legs
and get on about my day
i'm gonna need you two shot though i
mean how else do you say it
sir could you please not stand there sir
if you don't mind
i know i'm gonna need you know like all
of a sudden i'm your [ __ ] waiter
what do you need more bread get the [ __ ]
out of here
you know it's my fault you only brought
one metal detector i'm gonna go on
whatever
whatever [ __ ] door i want to go into
there's been
presidents my entire life i've never
[ __ ] with any of them
okay i got a clean record i was in
school
for a long goddamn time yeah i didn't do
well
but i never attacked the teacher you
think the first time i'm going to go
[ __ ] ape [ __ ]
i'm going to do it with the uh the
ticket terror of the free world
you know that's what the president is by
the way that's how i look at it you know
like when you go to the [ __ ] airport
and there's that person who goes okay
we're boarding down two
that's what he is on a global level
that guy doesn't have any power other
than the fact he's got a private chef
and they can shut off traffic they're
just [ __ ]
shuttling around this talking head
that's gonna go out there and say that
he's gonna do the right [ __ ] thing
but the reality is is he's gonna do
whatever the [ __ ]
the people who can whack them and make
it look like one dude did it
wants them to do that's what i think how
do you like that
you think i'm out of my [ __ ] mind why
i think i think i think you're out of
your [ __ ] mind what do you think
about that
huh it's not like i'm standing here
alone in my [ __ ]
boxers with a microphone talking to
myself
with nfl highlights on in the background
i'm a sane person
um is this going to get me on a watch
list
ah no i don't did you guys watch any of
the republican or the democratic
national conventions did you watch that
[ __ ]
what a bunch of [ __ ] babies you know
when are they just gonna grow up and
stop blaming each other
trying to take credit for [ __ ]
everything good that happens and then
you [ __ ] blame
the other side for all the bad [ __ ]
right when is there gonna be somebody
who just has the [ __ ] balls
to just get up there and be like listen
i know the last four years have been
really
[ __ ] up and there's nothing
there is nothing i would like to do more
than try to do something to fix it
okay but it is just completely out of my
control
you guys have no idea how [ __ ] big
this thing is
you have no [ __ ] idea dude andrew
luck
he he just does not look like a
quarterback
you know what he looks like he looks
like [ __ ] uh
oh jesus who's that [ __ ] irish
golfer who's doing well rory
mcilroy he looks like rory mcilroy on
human growth hormone
and you take that and you know and you
get muscles but your forehead becomes
twice as big too that's what he looks
like
um but good luck to him good luck
why why do i do this um
what am i talking about yeah why why
can't they just come out there and be
honest
you know well i love you i'm watching
like these [ __ ] these commercials the
republican commercials
and they're [ __ ] on [ __ ] barack
obama omaha whatever right and they're
going like
uh since he got in office the real
estate market collapsed
the [ __ ] it's like yeah all that [ __ ]
was in motion
when he came in all right and i'm not
even blaming george bush for that [ __ ]
he didn't do that [ __ ] all those
[ __ ] did you realize the president
makes like 400 grand a year
he like makes about as much as an nba
ref
how much power does that guy have why
did they pay that guy such so little
you don't think there's a [ __ ] reason
for that don't give me that horseshit
cause he's a public servant all right
if that was the answer in your [ __ ]
head you actually believed that story
when george washington you know that
story where
george said i cannot tell a lie
he's [ __ ] lying through his [ __ ]
wooden teeth his entire life how do you
think he got where he was at
you know you think politics was fair
back then
um i love how most you probably agree
with me and i'm yelling at you like you
don't but whatever that's what fuels me
look at serena running around
crushing her
you know what's funny about her she
looks like a [ __ ]
when she plays tennis she just looks
like a dude
and then the second it's over she turns
into a girl she's like oh my god
she just she does that thing where she
puts her hands straight up in the air
and jumped around in a circle
like some little girl that just won a
jump rope or some [ __ ]
um oh wow she won and then the other
girl put a towel over her head and
started crying
all right i'm not trying to be a dick
but she needs to do something about that
weave
okay she has a [ __ ] she has some [ __ ]
on diana ross wouldn't wear it
[Laughter]
she looks [ __ ] crazy she looks like
troy palamalu
geez i wouldn't say that to her face i
was actually one time
a long time ago i went to some sort of
show busy party
and she was there and she was one of the
she was [ __ ] totally proportionate
gorgeous let me tell you something right
now serena williams could [ __ ]
could choke slam me and there would be
nothing i could do about it
other than to be kicking my legs as she
had me up in the air
[Laughter]
that is the move of somebody who has
no solution to whatever hold they're in
there's just something about
you know what it is is when somebody
grabs you by the throat
there's just some your body goes into
the the flight mode
so your legs are already running the
second you get lifted up off the ground
you know i think your body understands
gravity and it realizes that at some
point you're coming back down again
and your body just in case you come down
on your feet
you automatically start running away
from whatever the [ __ ] just
picked you up by your throat um
anyways the [ __ ] with let's get back to
politics in a second
i got i gotta i gotta i can't be going
too deep into this thing i gotta do the
i gotta do my [ __ ] due diligence here
with the uh
with the advertising um legalzoom
everybody
all right you probably heard about
legalzoom if you're on youtube they got
a lot of advertising on there but let me
tell you something now i'm telling you
about it
okay so you gotta check them out because
these guys are these guys are awesome
um if you've been waiting for the
perfect time to start your dream
business
which is right now okay not really i
mean if you have
if you have a [ __ ] idea that's the
time to do it but when you have the idea
when you have all your ducks in a row
when you're ready to just walk out of
your cubicle
ball up your fist yet leave that middle
finger upright and stick it right his
mustachioed face
um but you want to be incorporated
before you do it uh legalzoom
all right you can incorporate your
business or form an llc
or a legalzoom at legalzoom.com starting
at just 99
bucks it's a bargain
um even you get some bad lawyer with
cheap shoes he's still going to charge
you at least 600
to do that they can do it for 99 bucks
on legalzoom.com
if you have a family um you know you're
not a [ __ ] you know you need to
these people need to be protect
protected um you can protect your family
and assets with the legal zoom will for
just 69 bucks
99 and 69. boy oh boy that's 168 bucks
you got yourself a business and a will
in the past 12 years
over 2 million americans have used
legalzoom for llc's wills trust
trademarks to come up with an invention
trademark right they've saved hundreds
even thousands of dollars versus going
to a traditional lawyer
legalzooms online process guides you
step by steps
and you get total customer support could
be much easier
they even have attorneys to help you out
uh if you need help through the legal
stuff
it's pretty cool man like if you don't
know what's going on you can actually
call them up and get legal
advice in case you didn't understand
what i just said all right start your
business and protect your family today
at legalzoom.com
you also get a special discount from
listening to this podcast make sure you
enter burr b-u-r-r
in the referral box at checkout for more
savings legalzoom is not a law firm and
self-help services are provided
at your direction in other words if you
get stuck call them up
they'll help you up and you'll you'll be
incorporated for 99
bucks there you go all right e-voice
everybody
wouldn't be great if you could have 59
000 phone numbers but only one cell
phone
well with e-voice they can make that no
not 59 000 but you can have a bunch of
them e-voice is your mobile phone at
work
um one of the great e-voice features
is music on hold uh
makes your business seem even more
professional as e-voice will treat your
clients and customers to music on hold
you can even set up your e-voice to run
promotional advertisements for your
company
while people are on hold instead of
having music evoice has the call
recording feature which is perfect for
doctors
lawyers real estate agents hiring
managers or any other professional
discussing contracts um
yeah it's basically you can have like
four or five different phone calls
phone calls phone numbers for the love
of god
phone numbers and um
they ring to your cell phone but nobody
has your real cell phone number
do you understand how that works it's
it's literally some buck rogers kind of
stuff going on
you guys you can have conference calls
with up to 95 people
um you can you can do wonderful things
with this or literally
live a double double life and marry
another woman and start another family i
mean the the the
the possibilities are limitless it's
easy to use you just press star two to
start and star
star two to stop okay perfect if you're
driving and can't write something down
something important down and you don't
wanna hit a jogger evil voice makes your
life easier and seems more professional
and seems more professional
for your free six-month trial go to
www.evoice.com
bill burr that's www.evoice.com
billboard
or go to the banner ad of my podcast
page at billboard.com and uh you'll be
on your way
you'll be on your way to getting out of
that dang cubicle
so anyways let's go back to the politics
what would you guys do
what would you do if a politician
actually went up there and just said
that
just say listen you know i came in here
for you guys but let me tell you
something i walked through those doors
walked through those marble columns and
um
my head spun around and i realized that
i didn't want to get whacked i didn't
want to have my
friends and family whacked and i decided
let me ask you this i'm all over the
[ __ ] place is this crazy
if i was running this country if you
were a construction company or whatever
the [ __ ] you whatever it is you do
a halliburton or whatever a general
electric
a mom-and-pop store and you got some
sort of governmental contract
if you [ __ ] did that [ __ ]
where because it's you know taxpayer
money
and you know and you just start charging
people like nine thousand dollars per
[ __ ] hammer
i think that's a treasonous act and you
should be you should [ __ ] go to jail
you know i know i don't get like i this
is what i think happens i think [ __ ]
corporations take their money
they bet on all the horses all right you
got the top two horses they throw money
at both of them
and then when they go in office whoever
wins owes them a favor they get a
governmental contract
and then their [ __ ] payback is they
look the other way when they charge nine
thousand dollars for a hammer
and then those [ __ ] corporate guys
give the kickback to the [ __ ]
head ticket terror in charge and they
help supplement his [ __ ] 400 grand a
year salary
that's what i think happens and then
once every four years they go out and
they talk to us [ __ ] morons and they
go everything good that happens because
of us
and we would have done more good stuff
if it wasn't for the other guys
and then the other guys come on oh we
did all the good stuff and those other
fits [ __ ] it's a joke
it's a [ __ ] joke and if you're
sitting there in one of those barbershop
quartet [ __ ] hats you know holding up
a [ __ ]
new hampshire sign you're you're a fear
of [ __ ] [ __ ]
you think you're in it you think you're
in the [ __ ] inner circle because
you're in there on a [ __ ] blue carpet
carpet the same color as the [ __ ]
toilet water of every [ __ ] person who
tried to be rich in the 70s
remember that [ __ ] people who had like
[ __ ] hd
blue before hd tv remember that they had
a furry [ __ ] toilet seat
just capturing every piece of [ __ ]
bacteria that bounced up out of the
goddamn toilet
remember that [ __ ]
you [ __ ] take a piss and the water
would turn green
that was entertainment when i was a kid
people would take a piss and everyone
gather around and look at then you flush
the toilet and you're
freaking out yeah and it turned blue
that's what we did before the internet
you know what but we weren't a bunch of
fat [ __ ] like these kids today
somehow fat kids i just want to slap him
right on the stomach right on the side
you know like a liver shop with like
like a like an
open hand see that nice [ __ ]
that would be that would be really
traumatizing to a kid especially as a
stranger if you
didn't even [ __ ] know you just came
up hey you know
hey what do you say that tubby and you
just [ __ ] slap him right on the
stomach
you could do [ __ ] like that back in the
day you know just called you know being
one of the guys
um anyways my patriots won yesterday the
[ __ ]
or yeah i guess i'll call it yesterday
the jets one
actually technically it is yesterday
it's 12 22 a.m nobody cares bill just
keep coming with the [ __ ] funny there
monkey boy
um you know what about looking about
mark sanchez responding
what do you jet fans think about tim
tebow
i don't know about that [ __ ] i feel like
if if
if sanchez if he's feeling it and he's
going down
to take him out one play that's almost
like icing your kicker but you're kind
of doing it to a quarterback
you know what i mean i don't [ __ ]
know i just don't think t i think tim
tebow's a [ __ ] winner i love the guy
but like i just don't think he is going
to make it as a quarterback he's got to
run too much he doesn't have good
footwork and i don't give a [ __ ]
who you are like
you can't you can only do that for so
long you gotta understand as fast as the
[ __ ] sec is
in college football you gotta understand
that the nfl
like most of the people in the sec don't
even make it into the nfl that's how
[ __ ] fast the nfl is right
now you think you're going to go out
there as a quarterback and start running
around all over the goddamn field
right and you think some [ __ ] 35 year
old hgh roided up [ __ ] linebacker
is gonna sit there and chase your ass
around the [ __ ] field all day he
isn't
he isn't he's gonna but they're gonna go
back in the huddle and they're just
gonna be like
next [ __ ] who's got a chance to
hit that jesus freak
okay anybody knocks him out i'm taking
you out to [ __ ] tony romo's tonight
steakhouse
not tony romos what the [ __ ] is it tony
roma he's got a great name for a
steakhouse
come on down to tony romos just picture
of fat tony romo
lately in his later on years you know
he's got a [ __ ] ring of fat around
his stomach and then a [ __ ]
jowls um
i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm saying i
just think uh whatever
jets look good condolences to bills fans
i know what that's like i haven't
experienced it in a while but i know
what that feels like to be all excited
and just get booted with a steel toe
right in your football balls
to start the [ __ ] season my
condolence to miami dolphin fans
it's just it's just the you know
you have hope you have that feeling okay
we're gonna turn it around you're down
there
you don't even get to bite into your
first [ __ ] chicken wing before you
know it it's over it's just it's it's
the worst
it's the worst and believe it or not i
actually gotta i have to i have to
give peyton manning props something i
never [ __ ] do because i'm a [ __ ]
not because he's a bad football player
it the fact that he didn't just
join he didn't pull a dwight howard and
just
join the [ __ ] san francisco 49ers
because if he jumped on that team it
there would have been no reason to even
play
look at chandler jones i called it paul
verzi
forcing a fumble sorry i'm looking at
the highlights of the patriots
um he could have just piled on he could
have just piled on with them and it
would have been [ __ ] over
um but he didn't you know i think it's
because he's a decent guy he's also he's
a country boy he doesn't want to be out
there in [ __ ] san francisco with all
that uh
all those homeo-type sexuals out there
he doesn't want to be out there right
he wants to be where thank god i'm a
country boy
thank god i'm a country boy is that
where that song's from
i remember going to mile high stadium
long time ago against the jets
the year after [ __ ] uh elway retired
and they played that song out there and
everybody started [ __ ] clapping their
hands and stomping their feet and i
literally got douche chills
you know if you think sweet caroline is
that sweet caroline's pretty bad
that that's a toss-up you know what i'd
say sweet caroline is worse
i know i brought this up before but red
sox fans who is actually still going to
go to games
can we please slowly but surely get rid
of that song in seventh inning just by
refusing to [ __ ] sing it can people
start making signs
something about just not singing that
[ __ ] song anymore
please for the love of [ __ ] god
anyways
here's what i think about the patriots
with [ __ ] lights out against the run
where they call in the box i think we're
great on d
alright our running game was great our
weak side
uh the guy took over from matt light i
was a little nervous about him and uh
when the [ __ ] titans abandoned the
run and they just went into the hurry up
offense and they just kind of went right
down the goddamn field and our corners
looked like they did the last couple of
years
i got a little nervous about that and i
know that they only did that on one
drive but it was the titans
you know what i mean it's not the
[ __ ] uh it's not the 49ers it's not
the [ __ ] packers or anything like
that so that made me a little bit
nervous
when uh when that [ __ ] happened so um
i don't know stupid-ass keith robinson
he goes what are you worried about
they're going to the [ __ ] super bowl
he really bugs me but i actually can't
give him [ __ ] cause i lost 50 bucks to
that [ __ ] i bet on the giants
like an [ __ ]
bet on the giants like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm actually a fan of the giants even
though
they beat me beat my team twice
i'm actually a [ __ ] fan of the giant
what's not to like
they stress defense they're a [ __ ]
class act
they win championships they're part of
the old nfl they got a great tradition
their [ __ ] defensive linemen are
are the future that's what defensive
lineman i think are going to look like
super-sized linebackers
and they're basically everything the
jets aren't
[Laughter]
they have class they have tradition
they don't have some blowhard as a
[ __ ] coach
you know actually i can't [ __ ] on rex
ryan you know what i i rented
i rented this [ __ ] uh for 16.99
goddamn raping 1699
adam sandler should have been in my
hotel room telling me why
he made the movie and all the cool stuff
about the movie i actually
rented uh that's my boy and i [ __ ]
loved it
i loved it started a little slow but
once
it stopped being little adam sandler it
became him it was [ __ ] hilarious
i really liked that movie you know
[ __ ] adam saying you know think about
em sandler's movies he just doesn't seem
like he gives a [ __ ]
in a good way like if he just likes
somebody he puts him in the movie and
you actually get to learn about adam
sandler as you're watching it
like rex ryan had like a [ __ ] decent
role
in that movie like a bunch of lines
and you just sit and they go oh adam
sandler's a jets fan
dan patrick's in there we did a great
job dude the cast
is just going down it is [ __ ]
hilarious and uh
nick schwartzen hilarious as always i
don't want to ruin
any of it but you know you know movies
now there's so much [ __ ] out there they
come and go really quickly
uh i give that one two [ __ ] thumbs up
all right
now don't be a [ __ ] and [ __ ] start
looking at the movie like you're gonna
like you thought you were gonna be
watching something like saving private
ryan
all right it's a [ __ ] comedy all
right
so you know take off your goddamn
[ __ ] you know whatever you can't take
that off and just sit there enjoy it i
actually really like the movie there you
go
thumbs up two freckled thumbs up from
this pasty [ __ ]
um anyways do you know some [ __ ]
actually had
the audacity to start sending me jokes
he said better jokes than yours this has
to be somebody [ __ ] around
this is his this is his joke um
well i'll tell you what he says first he
goes hey bill email me back you lazy
[ __ ]
uh this joke above this is one of my
free ones your mm podcast
is getting better sponsors but your
schtick is getting weaker
too many irons in the fire i will write
you one-liner tweets
and then parentheses and jokes that will
bring people out to your
shows buy your [ __ ] online and improve
your act
exclamation point fifty dollars each
patrice wanted them have your manager
respond
uh go [ __ ] yourself cordially and then
he says his name so here's his joke
all right and if you guys think this
dude is better than what i'm doing here
i'm gonna hire him and pay him fifty
dollars a joke
all right here's his joke high school
1972.
hey bro let's go to your house after
school watch three stooges
smoke some weed and light some farts
2012. dude let's go home do some bath
salts and shocker your sister the dog or
each
other exclamation point
there you go that's joke number that was
a freebie he's like a drug dealer that's
how good his [ __ ] is it's like the blue
meth
on breaking bad this [ __ ] guy he's
doling it out
you know what you [ __ ] if you're
listening right now and you're gonna
give me [ __ ] for my delivery
why don't you [ __ ] do me a favor and
and you record the jokes and tell me how
i'm supposed to say them and then i'll
play them on the podcast
and we'll let everybody decide out of
the [ __ ] blue
um anyways before i
go any deeper into the uh the podcast
here um with my old shtick
because i have too many irons in the
fire
um i wish i had too many irons in the
okay i have like 19 hobbies and i have
time for all of them that's how few
irons i have in the fire but thank you
sir
um i want to thank everybody who came
out
to uh the orlando improv i don't know if
i did that already because this is my
third attempt to turn trying to get
some momentum going in this podcast but
uh you know
i've never done stand-up here and the
place was packed all weekend even on
sunday night
with the return of peyton manning um
who looked [ __ ] great oh there's his
numbers right there
19 for 26 253 yards two touchdowns no
interest interceptions
go [ __ ] yourself and he doesn't have a
fuse next
his [ __ ] head's on a swivel um
anyways i want to thank everybody who
came out man i had a great
time [ __ ] beautiful women out here
jesus christ
gorgeous women gorgeous women some
[ __ ] rednecks and alligators
that's what you have to uh that's what
you have to look forward to
this [ __ ] girl in this last show came
out right you know people come out and i
stand there like a jackass and take
pictures with everybody
uh you know do the arms around the back
hey one two three
and then the [ __ ] camera never goes
by the way people
when you come up in the end you could
you just [ __ ] have the thing ready
just have the camera ready or the very
least as you hand it to
somebody else just just explain to them
it's hilarious like people in their 20s
love to hand their cell phones to people
in their 50s
it's like you're literally handing them
like a [ __ ] lightsaber they don't
know what to do with it
and then i'm standing there with
complete strangers we have our arms
around each other
smiling you know going all right you got
it is it going to happen is it going to
[ __ ] happen and you know
so whatever but anyways yeah so i'm
doing that [ __ ]
and uh to the [ __ ]
power of women it's just unreal
some girl came up all right yeah i get a
picture i put my arm around her back and
i'm just touching her back she had a
[ __ ]
back out all right and then immediately
i can't even i can't i'm saying i'm a
seventh grader i'm like thanks
show coming yeah i can't even [ __ ]
speak
44 [ __ ] years old you know what it
was is was i i was
i wasn't ready i couldn't like tell
my body to be like all right just
[ __ ] relax okay i wasn't ready i just
[ __ ] i was expecting
shirt and it was a [ __ ] woman's back
at
uh i i got flustered
[Laughter]
how [ __ ] weak is that 44 years old
and i got flustered so there you go
there you go look at rg3 look what the
[ __ ] he did
paul versi it's a lock dude
cancel christmas
it literally he actually actually says
griffin iii
i like how he has that like he's some
sort of landowner
what's his first name reggie barack what
the [ __ ] is his name
i'm so bad i just don't know anybody's
if you can't say rg 358 [ __ ] times
that's what he's going to become to me
you ever had a guy like that you called
him by his nickname so many times
and then one day he meets he starts you
know some girls interested in him
and you're like you know what's his name
fitzy
but what's his first name you know
because chicks always want to oh his
name's robert
the one who goes by rg white people
don't even call their kids robert
anymore
um
[Laughter]
you know that's that's a dying name and
so is my name like bill
who calls it a baby bill what was the
last time you heard somebody we had a
baby boy what'd you call them we called
them bill
do you understand that like my name's
gonna be like winston and one of those
old school [ __ ] ulysses names by the
time i'm [ __ ]
and i'm i'm on that point i'm [ __ ]
doing
80 36 in 36 years i'll be 80
all right and that cenegenics will be 36
years older and i will be [ __ ]
looking like i'm ready to be on mtv
cribs you know
but my head will still look [ __ ] up
you have you noticed that like with all
this [ __ ] to make you look younger like
nature
won't let you alter the head
you know because the head is that's like
your business card
you know and it's just like a nature
thing that just can't let you still get
ass at 80. you know
there's there's two there's just too
many [ __ ] people
they won't allow it um no jesus christ
what
let's read another [ __ ] maybe i do
have too many irons in in the fire
um kettle bells oh i asked about this
last week
somebody said hey bill i've been using
kettlebells for two months and i'm in
great shape
i was always in okay shape but the
kettlebells
fit into my ideal workout not time
consuming fun and i don't have to leave
my house also i feel like it can
i can rip someone's throat out after a
few sets
not that i would but hey you never know
when you'll need to
exactly exactly but i got to tell you uh
the guy who runs my podcast actually
helped me out with the link uh
that joe rogan um the joe rogan podcast
uh
put out and i actually watched that and
the only thing i'm concerned about
is with all that swinging of the
kettlebell
i'm worried about throwing out my back
you know what i mean
like do they have a video on the proper
form before i just get these things and
just start
swinging these anchors around and i'm
also worried about dropping it on my
[ __ ]
foot and don't even tell me that [ __ ]
hasn't happened
all right you're working out with
basically you know what a kettlebell
looks like it looks like one of those
old-school
irons from like the [ __ ] uh little
rascals days
where it was literally just a piece of
[ __ ] iron that you put a dish towel
around
and had a handle on it it's like that
except you melted it into a ball
okay you start [ __ ] uh
oh what a great text what a great text
the girl's back in town she got our dog
oh that was another great thing a couple
of fans came up and they they sho they
show me pictures of their pitbulls it's
the greatest that's the greatest
you i'll tell you right now if you don't
have if you have a dog and you didn't
get a pit bull you're really [ __ ]
missing out
they're just they're just the [ __ ]
greatest
they're they're great they like what a
dog should look like
they got the perfect dog head
they're in such great shape they look
like a little [ __ ] horse
you know and when you come home they got
this way of running
where they [ __ ] before they run in
your direction they got they gotta
lean back you know and then [ __ ] just
hurl themselves towards you all that
[ __ ] muscle coming at you
it's like you're you're right on the
[ __ ] rail at churchill downs
except it's running right here when it's
going to make your [ __ ] ear bleed
i can't wait to see my dog when i get
back
i actually have specific instructions
for my girl not to bring the dog down to
the airport
because i don't get the same kind of
whelping welcome because he's in the
[ __ ] car
you know i like to have the dog at the
house and then she lets it outside and i
come walking in
like one of those soldiers that came
back from war except i told jokes at a
strip mall
you know but it's my own little thing
right um
all right next email how far into this
[ __ ] are we
oh 45 minutes holy [ __ ] this is [ __ ]
how i'm flying
um all right [ __ ] list
bill i wake up at my girlfriend's house
she leaves to work
i can't find my socks she says i have
some
she says i have some just use mine and
leaves
i wake up later and i look for the sock
drawer top drawer
right um and i find this list with about
20 to 30 names on it
and my name is near the bottom oh no
some have check marks on them etc
i ask her about it and while she's
initially upset
it turns out to be her [ __ ] list
wow i don't have a [ __ ] i have a list in
my head
she actually made a [ __ ] list
dude you coined a phrase
she said she made it after we got
together
with some friends drunk one night she
then admitted to being
somewhat of a [ __ ] her words not mine
before we met but assures me that she
hasn't done anything since she met me
with anyone
else i do believe her but i totally blew
up on her
and we haven't been talking for a few
days i also look a bit creepy as to why
i went through her door
drawer it was in an envelope
yeah you know what it yeah you kind of
look creepy but she would have done that
to you
you know women call it snooping when we
do it it's [ __ ] creepy
anyways he goes i need some help here on
this one do i apologize
she already has do i just say [ __ ] it
and forget about it
what's nia's take on it god damn it
you know what
i'm gonna have to ask her take on that
one i'm not gonna have it on this
podcast when i when i go home
i fly him home tomorrow i'll try to uh
have an epilogue to this podcast
um or maybe tack it on to to the
following weeks
that is a great question because
i don't trust this girl
you know that when when a girl is that
[ __ ] free all right
and i know girls are getting mad why
can't we be as free as you
i'll tell you why you can't because you
don't have to work
at getting laid okay i can be sexually
liberated
i still have to go out to the bar
[Laughter]
i gotta do a [ __ ] tap dance
you know like me getting laid it's it's
like
somebody on [ __ ] uh american idol
trying to get that ticket to vegas
you know that's what it's like is it for
most guys anyways
to get laid even if you you're good at
it
it's it's like [ __ ] you know
it's it's it's not hot but you guys
anytime you want to [ __ ]
you can [ __ ] look at that girl tonight
came up with a back out i didn't know
that i put my hand and i wasn't ready 44
year old guy
i'm sitting there i can't even [ __ ]
talk
um so that's what i would be worried
about
she said she's a bit of a [ __ ] like
i don't know if that's a good thing or a
bad thing or if like uh
i i i don't know about that one she sat
down and she made a list
jesus christ 20 to 30 names now this is
the thing
i don't know how old she is all right
20 you know for a girl
20 to 30 names i don't think
is even that bad the fact that she well
i don't know but it might be even worse
because
they they are not honest
about their numb they do the exact
opposite of what we do guys we
exaggerate our numbers
they dial them [ __ ] back
like like women's
how many guys have you been with numbers
is like when
they put out how many people are
unemployed in this country
you know they try to keep that number
[ __ ] down it's the same thing
ah a [ __ ] list
i mean uh i i don't know i'd ever get
past that you sat around with your
friends
are your friends all [ __ ]
you know and it's not like they just sat
there going oh yeah you know
i [ __ ] you know bobby
phillip [ __ ] dakota trying to have a
[ __ ] modern name
um range rover whatever [ __ ] people
call kids and
boys now um
and then you know there's checks next to
him of of like
what she did with them or how good the
dick was
and uh i i don't know if that's one of
those things that they all [ __ ] do
and you just unfortunately peek behind
the curtain and you should let it go
i have no experience with something like
that
um oh this would have been a great nia
question
i have to do this with her and get into
a [ __ ] giant argument
but then i run the risk of possibly
getting
uh a [ __ ] preview of her [ __ ] list
which i don't want to know about i don't
want to know i mean i gotta be honest
with you i don't give a [ __ ]
at my age are you clean good okay what
do i think you were [ __ ]
in a in a goddamn bubble i hope you
banged enough guys and learned how to
[ __ ] i really do because i don't need
some fish in bed
you know just laying there mm-hmm i
haven't [ __ ] a lot of people
great isn't that great do you want a
pilot who hasn't flown a lot of planes
you know there's give and take okay you
got a girl who hasn't [ __ ] a lot of
guys ed you know
she sucks a dick like she's eating green
beans
that's the trade-off you know ah
dude that sucks that really sucks for
you why were you gonna wear one of her
socks to work though you know with a
little
[ __ ] chris everett ball hanging off
the back um
up a few bill i've been dating this girl
for three years now
she's the perfect mix of smart ass
sweetheart
good girl sexy for me that's my girl
that's
exactly it basically i'd be
a gigantic [ __ ] to [ __ ] up what i was
lucky enough to have delivered to me on
a silver platter
she also loves your stand-up and takes
on relationships
uh and on my takes on relationship if
that does anything for you
you don't get to [ __ ] please me dude
this is for you uh so what is your
problem you ask
i met her and started dating her in
college when she was
a d1 athlete with an unbelievable body
if i may tug my own dick for a bit i
beat out current starting nfl
i beat out a current starting nfl qb who
was trying to get with her at the time
that's [ __ ] awesome at the time i met
her by not playing the [ __ ] card
uh gaining weight was never an issue as
befo
before she graduated she was always in
shape through regular practices
since then she's been slowly putting on
weight to where it's now getting noticed
by my friends
and family anytime i mention it to her
she gets all apologetic but we'll never
do
a whole lot to fix it or we'll stop
after trying for a week or two
um so that i'm not a hypocrite i stay in
as good a shape as i can while eating
real food and drinking
uh real beer working out enough to
maintain i absolutely love this girl
and this isn't a major issue now but if
i'm one going one day gonna ask this
girl to marry me
i would like to know that the current
trend will improve
what do i say or do i without sounding
like a shallow [ __ ]
or am i a shallow [ __ ] no you're not
a shallow [ __ ]
nobody wants to [ __ ] get with
somebody who's in shape and then watch
him slowly become a tub of [ __ ] that's
not fair to the person that you're with
you know it isn't look it'd be one thing
if she went out and she had a couple of
kids
you the the physical toll and the
[ __ ] nine months of hell that they go
through
you got to give them a pass on that you
would be a total [ __ ] if you brought
that up
but the thing is the fact that she
hasn't even had a [ __ ] kid yet she's
sitting around eating [ __ ] cheetos
getting all mushy you know you don't
want a mushy girl
i don't know how to uh how do you do it
uh not this is how you do it don't say
it the way i just said it
i would say um
oh the yankees won 13-3 over the orioles
are the yankees kind of choking i don't
even watch baseball
oh man i want to see the [ __ ] orioles
and pirates rematch i see like the
kansas city royals in there are they in
there
is that what's going on you know this is
one of these classic years where people
go see
it doesn't matter if you spent 200
million dollars right once every four or
five years
this happens oh that's great so 80 of
the time
you know it's going to be yankees and
red sox that's such a [ __ ]
it's such a tragedy what happened to
[ __ ] mlb and now it's going to happen
to the nba um
anyways what do you say
i think i've answered this question
before haven't i
how did you just got to be like listen
just tell her listen i love you to death
we're young
okay and if we're already getting just
keep saying we if we're already getting
out of shape at this age
it's going to lead to health problems
and like i want you to be around
you know i want you to enjoy life i
don't want us to be this couple
just say listen i get out of shape every
once in a while try to stay on top of it
i can help you
we can work out together that's a good
one if you work out together
start going on hikes they love that [ __ ]
looking at flowers and [ __ ]
bumblebees and stuff
you know just hold your hand act like
you're being romantic and walk fast
[Laughter]
um just do [ __ ] like that it's you know
look you get one body you just you got
to treat it right
you've you know it's like a car you get
a car you never wash it you don't change
the oil looks like [ __ ] [ __ ]
all right just say look you're hot you
turn me on i want to
[ __ ] bang you all the goddamn time
all right
i'm saying this for your own good i know
you don't want to hear it and then and
there's got to be something that i'm
doing
that's bugging you let me hear that just
maybe a little tit-for-tat no pun
intended
um do it that way but dude you're not in
the wrong you're not in the [ __ ]
wrong like
that that'd be like if if a guy was
sober when he meets somebody and all of
a sudden becomes an absolute [ __ ]
drunk that's not fair to the other
person
so you know like i said i mean i i
stopped showed if if they have like
you know a couple of kids i mean it's
just
that is what it is okay they [ __ ]
sacrifice their body
so you could have the joy of having a
child you should shut the [ __ ] up then
but i mean but if they're getting to a
point where it's like a health concern
like they're gonna have a heart attack
or a stroke god forbid you know you you
have to say something
my grandfather you said to my uh my
grandmother
he said just say to us hey you better
watch it
that's it and she knew what that meant
and you know he
he'd let her gain like 10 and just said
hey you know you better watch it
[Laughter]
all right anyways bill i've listened to
your podcast since the beginning but i
can
i cannot recall you ever rating oh ever
ranting or pondering the subject
of shad and freud
uh which is german word it's a german
word that means taking
joy in the pain and misery of others
um and some reason it just cut off there
hang on a second i want to read this one
where the [ __ ] is it hang on god damn it
bill
you're really the worst uh there because
there's there's there is no word for
this in english i guess the germans
just have a more realistic understanding
of human nature
would love to hear your thoughts on this
phenomenon i'd rather give you
my thoughts on that condescending
comment there is a word for that in the
english language it's called a hater
you're a hater you want to see everybody
else fail
you don't like when [ __ ] people win
you know what i mean
i guess germans have a more realistic
understanding yeah or you [ __ ]
committed genocide 60 years ago maybe
that maybe you guys are a bunch of
blue-eyed [ __ ] psychopaths over there
maybe maybe that's what it is
can anybody write anything about this
[ __ ] country
from another country without being a
[ __ ] all right
and i'm not saying we're not a bunch of
[ __ ] over here but you know
take a deep breath in your country and
you tell me what you smell
um no i guess we are just more advanced
than you and we just don't
have a more realistic perspective really
maybe we grew up behind a [ __ ] wall
we would have felt the same goddamn way
if we try to exterminate a group of
[ __ ] people
because we were too stupid
to [ __ ] blame the right people which
is those blue blood [ __ ] at the top
why don't we all just join hands and
walk over to the rothschild's house why
don't we do that at some point
um dilemma bill would you rather fight
four chimpanzees
to get out of a burning building i would
lose i would lose to one or never be
able to turn
left for the rest of your life
uh i'd rather never be able to turn left
for the rest of my life
in the monkey scenario they have sticks
and you have an axe
dude give me a [ __ ] break
isn't it enough that a monkey has the
strength of six men can rip my foot off
my
ball bag and then tear my face off
while hanging from one a [ __ ] drain
pipe
or a ceiling fan i guess i should have
said
and i have an axe in the turning
scenario you can never turn
left in a car on foot on a bicycle
never um
yeah i would i would obviously just i
would never go left
there's a way to go left by going right
you know
you know like all i have to do is drive
up to the street i want to make a left
on
and then they just go right and i go
around the block and then i pass the
street i was just on i make another
right and another right and there i am
would actually teach me patience and the
other scenario
um i get to turn left but i don't have a
face
ball bag or a left foot so i'm to say i
don't
that's a good dilemma though dude have
you not been keeping up on monk i guess
it's not a chimpanzee what kind of
monkeys are they they're those little
ones that throw their [ __ ] at you at the
zoo
but those those little [ __ ] i don't
want an axe
they're too quick those things would
just jump on you
you don't bring an axe to a monkey fight
sean connery said that one time
um i want a fire hose
if i have a [ __ ] fire hose and
they're at least 30 feet away from me
and we're in a room
that's that's what i would do and i get
michael vick's [ __ ] uh flak jacket
i would definitely do it um
all right is that it okay couple more
little advertising and then i'll tell
you a quick little story
um all right stamps.com everybody what
if everything uh
what if you could take care of
everything you mail or ship
in a way that saves you time money and
hassle well you can with stamps.com
stamps.com
is more than just stamps it's your 24 7
solution for sending letters and
packages within the safety
within the wonderment within the the
angel dust of your own home apartment or
tent city
with stamps.com buy and print official
us postage using your own computer and
printer
it's like having the post office right
at your desk for
all of your postal and shopping needs
stamps.com will even give you a digital
scale so you can get the extra uh so you
can get the extra postage you need on
any letter or package
then the mailman picks it up i actually
use stamps.com to send all my dvds out
to the wonderful strip malls that i
perform
in it's so easy so convenient right now
i have a special offer
when you use my last name bur b-u-r-r
you get a no-risk trial plus 110
bonus offer includes a digital scale and
up to 55 dollars in free postage you
guys gotta do this man
if you wanna phase out going down there
and standing in that line only and have
somebody
stick that thing up and say next window
please uh
just takes a few minutes to get started
so go to stamps.com right now before you
do anything else click on the microphone
at the top of the home page then type in
bur
that's stamps.com and enter bur
all right so this concludes another
wonderful
monday morning podcast um thank you to
everybody who's been going on to
amazon.com
through my website on the podcast page
clicking on the banner and buying stuff
uh we've been doing real well we've been
raising a lot of money
for the uh wounded warriors project
i owe those i owe those guys some money
i've gotten two checks in i haven't
given them a dime
so i owe those guys a nice little chunk
of change thanks to you it works for all
of us
amazon.com and gamefly.com how would you
like to have 8 000 video games free for
two weeks
go to billboard.com click on the podcast
page and check it out
click on the link to gameflyduck or just
go to gamefly.com
bill burr right and you're in there okay
now where am i going to be next week
everybody
my white trash redneck tour continues
orlando you guys were the [ __ ]
beautiful people everybody had their
teeth it wasn't rednecky at all there
definitely were alligators
all right but i was completely wrong
about you guys now charlotte
you know what are you guys gonna do you
guys gonna sit back and let orlando
[ __ ] show you up
you know give me some [ __ ] to do i don't
want to be a shut-in like i did this
week i got six [ __ ] weeks in a row
on the road and i swear to god this
podcast is really difficult to do
if i just stay in my [ __ ] hotel room
because i got to go out whenever i go
out and i do something i always make an
ass out of myself then i have my comedy
i have my stories that's how it works
everybody
all right that's the podcast for this
week um new york city after charlotte
after charlotte i go to jacksonville
after jacksonville i go to cincinnati go
bananas
um then i have a week off and then the
18th through the 21st
i am in synth uh sydney
australia ah [ __ ] what's the name of the
place
we actually uh we're selling tickets so
well down there that we're gonna add a
show
how [ __ ] unreal is that the other
side of the world in the other [ __ ]
hemisphere
um we're gonna be adding goddamn shows
and what is that people that's the power
of the [ __ ] podcast isn't that
tremendous
um and i'm psyched because i was worried
i was just going down there doing one
show
which is a lot of pressure to fly 14
hours down there get one shot at it
imagine if i ate my [ __ ] balls
and then just had to get back on a plane
and fly 14 hours the other way
uh give me some [ __ ] to do in sydney
help me out guys
help me out i'm gonna have no life over
the next five six weeks i would really
appreciate it
okay that's the podcast for this week
once again thanks to everybody in
orlando like the
the turnout was unfucking believable we
were packed tonight on a sunday night
of football sunday there was steeler
fans and bronco fans in the [ __ ]
crowd
tivo in the [ __ ] so they could come down
and see my act it means the world to me
all right that's it i'll see you in a
white trash city near you
go [ __ ] yourselves don't take any [ __ ]
uh
hasta orisa this is my spanish for this
week until next time go [ __ ] yourselves
you